Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert. Welcome to lecture 9. We're going to continue talking about
functions and function libraries and we're going to concentrate on data flow today. In your reading
you'll also read about two control structures, the switch statement, the conditional operator,
and the do while loop that we didn't cover earlier. But I won't cover those in this lecture.
So we're going to start with a little review on separate compilation and testing. So make sure
that you have gone to week 3. In week 3 on Tuesday click the lecture exercise, click the link for the
starter form, and in the starter form this is what we're going to do. We're going to recapitulate the
material from the textbook section covering libraries and testing. So we're going to create
a library named exlib that has two functions min and max in the namespace ex. So it'll be in the
namespace ex which will return the appropriate value from three input parameters of type double.
So we're going to place our code in the folder exlib. This is in IC9 exlib already. We're going
to open the client file named cpp, client cpp, and the run test function. We're going to add a
begin function test and an end function blocks for max and one for min. We're going to create a
file wide epsilon concept constant and then we're going to write three different assert double equals
tests for each function. And then we're going to type make client. It should fail to compile because
we've only tested our functions. We haven't yet declared or defined them. Then we're going to
shoot a screenshot of the error messages we get. So remember the client program is the program that
tests your program. So go ahead and add your student ID here. I'm going to close that down
there. And this is a skeleton for our testing framework. So we're going to write a function
test for max and we're going to write a function test for min. So notice I copied the begin function
test and the end function test. So we are going to write functions that test a double and so we're
going to need a file wide constant here. Actually it doesn't need to be file wide. We can just well
let's make it file wide like it says. So const double k epsilon equals 1.0 e to the minus 14.
I'm trying to use the Google constant style now instead of the capitalized. Okay so this one
min and max are going to take three arguments. We're going to return the smaller or the larger
or the smaller and max we're going to turn the larger. So we're going to use this version of
assert double equals. So let's call our function here. So it's going to be in the namespace EX
and we're going to call max and we want the max from 1.1 1.01 and 1.011. Okay so they're very
close together. Our tolerance value here is going to be k epsilon and what we expect to get out of
that the largest of those is 1.011. I'm going to write three tests because I want to make sure
that the code is actually doing what it says. And so what I'm going to do is notice this is
the last place in this this is in the last place. In the second one I'm going to move it into the
second place and in the third one I'm going to move it into the first place. So 1.011 1.1 and
1.011. I'll make that 0.1 and I'll move 1.1 down here. Yeah and so this kind of makes sure since
we have three input parameters we have three tests to make sure it can identify what the
largest one is. For a second function we're going to run the same tests. I'm just going to copy that
down there. But instead of the max function I'm going to call min. And instead of 1.01 oh actually
that's not the maximum here the maximum of each of these is 1.1 right. And let's move that 1.1 over
here. So there it's in the first there it's the last and we'll do 1.011. Okay so we have it the
first second and third we got back 1.1 that is the maximum. Here the smallest one is 1.01 and
1.01 is in the middle there at the end there. Let's move it to the front here. So again we're
checking three different positions to get 1.01. Okay so that's just how testing works. You write
a function you call your function you you write an assert equals method after you put in this boiler
plate in the assert equals method you get the actual value by calling the function you're trying
to test. Then you put in the expected value here and when this runs it will call your function it
will compare these and it'll give you a plus sign or a negative sign. It didn't pass and tell you
why it didn't pass. So let's go ahead let's open a terminal on EXLIB here open a new integrated
terminal. Yeah let's make that a little bigger so we can see it and let's do make client. Okay so
notice we got a whole bunch of errors EX has not been declared and so this is the picture we'll
take for our first one that says EX has not been declared. So again notice we have tested our
functions which is what you'll normally do first but we haven't even yet declared them or defined
them. Okay so now we're going to test them we're going to create a header file extreme.h it'll
contain the prototypes for our two functions you need to remember to add the header guards the
namespace and document each of the functions using the javadoc documentation. Then include the file
in the appropriate place in client.cpp and make client again. Our program should now compile but
not link and when it does we'll paste a picture of that error message. So again the error message
you're going to have in your first picture is going to be like this. Let me just shoot a picture
I'm going to use the Windows Windows shift s and so that picture is going to look something like
this. And now we're going to do the second part. So let me do that let me create the new file so
I'll just right-click here on EXLIB new file and I'll call this file extreme.h and in extreme.h
I'm going to start with the header guards if endef extreme.h defined extreme.h endif I'm
going to put the file header at the top at file extreme.h at author and at version or at date
and close that. So there's my file comment here are my two functions but first I need a namespace
so namespace EX. Inside my namespace I need my two functions so double min double a double b
double c and double max double a double b double c my documentation comment for that
slash slash finds smallest of a b and c or of three doubles at param a at param b second number
and at param c and at return the smallest of a b and c. Put a T on the end of that one and finally
backspace and end that. Okay I can comment I can just copy this because the comments going to be
almost the same for the second one. This is just going to be the largest of course.
And we have one more comment to do.
Okay we need to comment the namespace as well. Okay so here's our source code for the prototype
and we should now be able to do again exactly the same line make client. Oh what did I forget?
I forgot to come over here and my client still doesn't know about that so I need to include
Xtreme.h. Now I've written my function tests for this so now let's try it we should get a
different set of errors. Make client. Notice that looks entirely different so when I have
make client this is an entirely different kind of error. Again for my picture I'm gonna take
something like that. Undefined references. So we've declared them now we can come over
here and paste our second picture in there. So now we're going to create an implementation file.
We have used the functions. We have by calling the functions in our client we have declared
the functions and we can see that that compiles but does not yet link. Now we're going to create
an implementation file Xtreme.cpp containing the implementation of the two files. We have
to include the header file and any other library functions such as string or C math. Then we're
going to create a make file and we should now be able to build and test our program with make test.
So let's add our third file here. New file and this new file is going to be Xtreme.cpp.
And we're going to include Xtreme.h. I'm going to assume I don't need any functions in here so I'm
not going to use the using namespace or anything. And so I'm going to go to Xtreme.h. I'm going to
get my whole namespace. I'm going to copy it over into Xtreme.cpp. I'm going to get rid of
these documentation comments. We don't need them inside the implementation. I'm going to put on a
return zero. I'm going to stub them out by removing the semicolon, giving it a body and
returning just a dummy value. Now I'm going to add one more file, the make files. So again right click
new file, make file. In the make file I'm going to create a variable for the exe and I'm going to
call that test Xtreme. I'm going to create a variable for the object files. So I need client.o
and really what I'm doing down here is looking for the cpp files. Client.o CS150 check.o Xtreme.o
and that looks like all the cpp files. Now I'm going to do my rule so the object file depends
on the executable. That's what I'm trying to build. The executable depends on the object files
and our rule for building that is to use the C++ compiler. Think of those xx's as pluses on their
sides. Pass in the options called the CXX flags. Pass in the input which is the object file and
let's make these, let's put an S on the end of this and put an S there. OBJS, OBJS, OBJS. I'm
not quite sure. Oh because I didn't put the dollar sign in the right place. Syntax highlighting
helps quite a bit right? And then -0 and I'm going to build the executable. Okay I'm also
going to make a make test. So this is a pseudo target. So test relies on the executable being
built. That's the target is the test and the dependency is the executable and for that I'm
going to do ./, select the current directory, run the executable and because we're using the
testing framework -t will run the tests when we do it. So let's try that. Let's clear this off.
So make should work with no errors. It should just come back. It should build all of those
object files and the executable. Make test should run our tests. All of our tests should pass because
we're passing in zero as the return. We just stubbed out the answer but all of our tests run
correctly. So let's do the last part. The last part is just figuring out which are the smallest
of A, B and C. So if A is less than B and A is less than C we're going to return A. If B is less
than A and B is less than C we're going to return B and if none of those are true we're going to
return A. Now I probably should do it the way I've been showing you do it. So double result
equals A else else if result equals B else
else and this of course should be C return result. Now if these are all the same it will
return the farthest one and return C in this case. Let's put the same thing down here for the minimum
or maximum that was minimum. So if A is greater than B and A is greater than C and B is greater
than A B is greater than C. Okay so there's our implementation. Let's test it out. Let's open up
the thing here. Let me move that over so that the tests actually appear better and let's clear that
with ctrl L and let's do make test. Okay and so all of those correctly give us the value. Can we be
sure that they are working correctly? Yes because we figured out manually what the answer should be
and put it into the testing function the assert function the assert equals function. Okay so let's
look at what we've done here. So we created the client we wrote three assert equals tests for both
min and max. We built it and we did a screenshot with the error message. Then we created the header
file. We added the header guards to the header file. We added the documentation and then we did
make client again and we got a different error message than we got up here. So what here the
min and max were undeclared undeclared. Here min and max were declared so we didn't get a compiler
error but they were undefined because we hadn't implemented them. So then we implemented them. We
walked through those six steps that I told you to memorize and wrote the stubs. The test ran but
didn't give us the correct answer and then we went back in and did the implementation. And so the
tests worked and you can go ahead and shoot your final screenshots there. I'm not going to do it
on this thing but they want a screenshot of your source code for extreme.h, a screenshot for the
source code for extreme.cp, for client.cp, do make test to get a screenshot of running client,
a screenshot of your make file and let's do the generated documentation. I will do that for you.
Okay so remember what we need to do for Doxygen is we need to do a Doxygen doxy file. Okay we're
going to get an error. Okay so Doxygen is already installed on mine. If it is not, if you get Doxygen
does not exist or it's not a file or something like that, do apt sudo apt-get install Doxygen.
Next do, see I've already installed, I've already got it installed here. Next do Doxygen - g. That
will create a doxy file. Now I'm just going to go ahead and do this without changing any of the
changes and that's just Doxygen doxy file. It generates all of the files. It tells me there's
some problems down here and those are things we wanted to fix before. Then I'm going to come over
here and notice I have this HTML folder. I'm going to right-click on the HTML folder, open in an
integrated terminal. Okay I'm going to say HTTP - server and I'm going to serve those pages up so
we can look at them in a web browser. Now it'll give us back the URL so you can do ctrl-click to
open that URL in your web browser and then just find the index.html and open it. Now on the index
you notice we have one namespace ex and click that namespace ex and you'll see the documentation,
the generated documentation for those two functions that we added as javadoc comments.
Okay when you're done don't just leave that server running use ctrl-c to close the server.
Use ctrl-c to close the server. All right let's go on to this week and let's talk about function
signatures. Now in languages like C function names must be unique. That means you ended up
inventing new names to do the same work as another function if you had different kinds of arguments.
So in the C standard library there's the function abs which works for integers, there's fabs which
works for floating point numbers, and there's elabs which works for longs. In C++ standard
library we use the same name for all of those functions for those three different functions.
So how can we do that in C++? Well in C++ two functions can have the same name if the number
of arguments they require differs or the type or order of their arguments differ. So this combination
of the method name, the parameter types, number, and order is called the function signature. And
it acts like DNA to uniquely identify a particular function under the hood to the linker to the
compiler. Now an overloaded function is a function that has the same name but a different signature
and of course a different implementation or a different body. So here are four functions all
named f. So one takes an int, one takes an int and a double, one takes a double and an int. So notice
these both take the same kind of arguments but in different order. And one takes three arguments
double, double, double. If we looked inside the object code we'd see those functions have a
different name. This is called a mangled name. And so the name for the double, double, double is
underscore capital Z 1 F DDD. Right? So F plus three doubles. Here's F plus double and an int.
Here's F and an int and a double. And here's F with only a single int. A single int. So this
mangle name is used internally by the compiler and linker to uniquely identify a particular
function. And that's how overloading works physically and why it was allowed in C++. In C
function names are not mangled internally. Now when you call a function the compiler has to
know which function you're trying to call. It has to have some way of telling exactly which
function you mean. And this is called overloading resolution. So you resolve overloaded functions
first by looking at all of the functions with the same name. These are called the candidate set.
So in our four examples previously we would pick up all of the F's. Secondly we go through the
candidates and we see how many have the correct number of convertible arguments. So in the
previous one if I called F 1 comma 2 it would look through, it would throw out the first one which
only took an int and the third fourth one which took three ints and it would leave a viable set
of only two functions. The one that takes int and double and the one that takes double followed by
int. Then it would look for an exact type match. Well in this case I don't have any exact type
matches. I'm calling it with two ints but I have a function that takes an int and a double and I
have a function that takes a double and an int. So I don't get that test at all. I skip it entirely.
Now I look to see if there are any partial matches. Well the int and double matches one
argument, the first argument, but the double and int also matches one argument. So I have two that
match partially. Then if I don't have any partial matches but I can do conversions, I have the
correct number of arguments and they're convertible, I try that. Well again I have int double and
double int. Both of those work and if none of them, if I am not down to one specific function
at this point, I have what's called ambiguity. There is more than one viable conversion.
So let's look at a couple of questions. Consider this function call. Which of these function
overloaded functions will be invoked? So I'm calling g one two. Now notice I'm not using the
return type but even if I was that return type is not used as part of the resolution. However if I
was assigning it to something then that expression would look at the return type and so b and d
would not work in that case. In this case however my candidate set is a b c d and e or a b c and d.
All of them have the same name. They're all in the candidate set. Second, find out the ones with the
correct number of convertible arguments. Well this takes two, this takes two, this takes two, this
takes two. They're all convertible so my viable set is the same as my candidate set. A, B, C, and D
are all in the viable set. Number three, see if there are any exact matches. Well int and double
it matches but not double. The double doesn't match here. The int matches there. Int, int, oh that
matches exactly. So this must call the function c. This must call the function in number c. Let's try
another one. So look at this function call. So I have fn with 1.0, 2.0, and 3.5. So first what are
the candidates? A, B, C, and D. I have four functions named fn. Second, what's the viable set?
Well can I convert 1 to an int? Yes. 2.0 to a double? Yes. 3.5 to a double reference? No.
This is not a variable that can be converted to a double reference. So A is out. How about B?
1.0 to an int? Yes. 2.0 to an int? Yes. 3.5 to a double reference? No. B is out. How about C?
Okay, okay, and okay. Okay so C is okay. And D? Int, int, int. Again all of these are convertible
so my viable set now consists of C and D. Do we have an exact match? Double, double, double.
Nope, we don't have an exact match. Do I have a partial match? Well C matches one argument. D
does not match any arguments. So in this case C will be the function that's chosen in that case.
Yeah the second thing we want to talk about here is default arguments. So a function can have both
mandatory and optional arguments. So this is how we would write the function. The function F here
requires you to pass in one argument, but if you don't pass in B or C those default argument values
will be used. Okay and that means we can call the function F in three different ways. If I call it
with one argument then B will be set to the default value 3 and C will be set to the default value 4.
If I call it with two arguments A will be set to 7, B will be set to 2, and C will use its default
value 4. And if I call it with three arguments then A will be 8, B will be 5, and C will be 3.
So even though I have one single function not all the arguments are required. Now there are some
rules about this. First you cannot have a mandatory parameter after an optional one,
and secondly you cannot have any references. So this would be illegal. I have provided an
optional value for A and I have required them to put in B. So if I call F of 1, which one is it
supposed to do? Is that supposed to go in the first argument? It just won't work. So that's illegal.
No mandatory parameters in B after an optional parameter. And A is optional.
Secondly I can have an int ref A. That's perfectly fine. But int ref B equals 3 is not fine.
So you cannot have default arguments for reference parameters. Again 3 is... what is B a reference to?
3 is not a variable and B would have to be a reference or another name for a existing variable.
So we're going to try this, our second example today. We have this function that has main.
I want to print hello and I want to print the A cosine of minus 1. And I expect to get out when I
do that hello, which is just printing the words hello, and I expect to get out 3.1459.
Now I also expect to be able to call the function with a string goodbye and a second argument.
That's going to add a new line and I would expect to get goodbye and a new line. Notice I didn't
have a new line when I just did print without the second argument. And finally I expect to be able
to print the A cosine with an argument for the new line and an argument saying how many decimal
places. Notice when I printed it up here I just got the default number of decimal places. So we're
going to have a function with overloaded arguments. And we're going to do this one not in our
not in our CS50 IDE, which we're done with for today, but in our code check.
Okay so we're going to write two functions, the void function print and the second prints a double.
And both have default bool arguments and the second has an additional default argument
indicating how many decimals to use.
So here's the main function we had. I'm going to make that a little bigger so we can see the whole
thing. Okay so our first function, both these are void functions, so void print and void print.
Okay the first one is going to take a const string reference and a bool
newline equals false.
Okay so by default if they don't pass the second argument it prints it as a new line.
This one is going to take a double. I'll just call it num.
It's going to take a bool newline equals false.
And then it's going to take an int
digits precision. I'll call it precision. And here I'm going to pass in a value
that is going to indicate, so minus one is going to indicate that I don't want to pass
in a precision. I want to be able to say I don't want any decimals printed.
So two overloaded functions, two versions of print and two
optional parameters here, one optional parameter here. So this is just going to say cout,
let's give that string a name shall we?
cout str and then if newline cout endo. So that one was pretty easy right?
Okay let's look at the second one. So in this one we're going to say cout num
and if newline cout endo.
But here we need to decide what to do about the precision. So if precision
not equal to minus one, then cout fixed set precision.
Precision.
And so that'll allow us to call this with print the a cosine of one with a newline
and 17 digits of precision there. Okay let's try it.
Okay and that worked for the first one here and it worked for the second one and the third one.
So we got three out of three on that. So go ahead and take a picture of the
testing code here and take a picture of your two overloaded functions with default arguments.
Okay so that's it for our exercises today. Now I want to talk a little bit about parameter
categories and data flows. You'll need this in programming exam four. So input parameters
are the normal type that you have in java and in python. The information flows into your function
when you call the function. So the data inside a flows into the square root function here
and the return value n flows out of the square root function. Because the information is flowing in
I can provide a literal. That's because the parameter for square root
gets a copy of what is ever is called to the function. Now output parameters work differently.
With output parameters you supply a variable. You pass that variable to the function. The function
fills it in and you use it afterwards. So the cn object has a member function called get.
Get will read a character but it doesn't return the character from the function. It returns whether
it was able to read a character or not. So ch goes into the function empty and it comes out full.
Because of that when we have an output parameter we cannot use a literal. We can only use a variable.
Now input output parameters are where the data flows both ways. If I have two variables a and b
and I call the function swap, a had one value going in and when the function is over it has
a different value. So variables a and b are modified when I call the function swap.
Now when you look at your functions and you look at a problem you have to decide which way
the data is flowing. So for input output parameters and output parameters you will
always pass them by reference after the type for all type categories. Now in Doxygen we can add a
little specification to the end of the param tag that says it's in out or out. So people reading
that will understand that it's an output parameter or an input output parameter.
For input parameters when you're calling a function and the data is flowing into the
function only and not flowing back out through the same variable the way you declare it depends
on the type of input. For library types all library types all class types including string
you will pass by const reference. You will never pass by value. We don't do this because it's
illegal. We do it for efficiency. It uses less memory and it is faster. For the built-in types
that means int, double, char and so forth we'll pass by value. We won't use const or
the reference symbol for the built-in type input parameters. Only for the output parameters.
Now I have a second. Often you don't know is that an input or output parameter.
So let me give you a second checklist. You really should memorize both of these.
Is the parameter a primitive or built-in type? Okay in other words is it an int, a char, a double,
a bool, one of those. If it is, is the function supposed to change the argument? If it is you
pass by reference. So notice that the swap function has a reference parameter for the
left-hand side and the right-hand side. All other functions if the function does not change the
argument you will always use pass by value. Again no const, no reference, no nothing.
For object or library types always use pass by reference and then if the argument is unchanged
use a const reference. So again you need to memorize these checklists and in the next
lecture we'll do an exercise just to make sure that you understand these concepts.
Okay that's it for this lecture. I'll see you next time.